[Musique]
la parole entrepreneurs ça permet
d'accueillir des entrepreneurs pour
permettre à nos collègues quels qu'ils
soient sénateurs sénatrice de rencontrer
des chefs d'entreprise un petit peu
originaux efficace innovant c'était le
cas ce matin avec Thierry Marx sur le
sujet qui nous intéresse à la délégation
de la formation et de l'emploi qu'est-ce
que j'attends des échanges comme ce
matin simple c'est de faire cette
courroie de transmission entre ce qui se
passe dans nos territoires sur nos
terroirs dans nos terroirs et le Sénat
c'est à dire que pour pouvoir activer
des solutions plutôt que d'aller
chercher des coupables donc il faut
mettre tout le monde en ordre de
bataille parce qu'on voit bien que cette
société est fracturée je vais reprendre
les vieilles phrases du covid c'est
symptômes diagnostic traitement et
travailler ensemble sur trouver des
solutions pour cette société puisse
aller vers 2050 2070 avec beaucoup
d'épanouissement donc c'est c'est dans
ces lieux qu'on peut travailler partager
échanger et surtout passer à l'action
évidemment d'aller au fond des choses de
comprendre ces motivations comment il en
est venu là quels sont ces concepts sur
lesquels il s'est appuyé dans le cas
présent Thierry Marx a été chercher des
gens extrêmement éloignés de l'emploi
pour en douce semaine en faire des
personnes qui a 90% sont embauchés à la
sortie de cette formation accélérée donc
c'est ça qu'on vient chercher des
recettes pratiques
réussie dans des expérimentations qui
vont nous permettre d'illustrer nos
travaux pour nous aujourd'hui le Sénat
c'est mettre du temps entre l'émotion et
l'action et de se dire avec le Sénat et
bien on observe
on regarde on apprend et ensuite on peut
passer à l'action donc avec le regard du
Sénat on est en capacité de se dire la
République française a encore cette
capacité à observer intelligemment les
choses à les analyser et à passer à
l'action pour améliorer le sort de nos
concitoyens et de le ramener nos
concitoyens dans l'idée d'un projet
commun
[Musique]